[Music]
what exactly happened in the country
that was
at the time the sixth richest country on
the planet and the third richest if you
include micro states of monaco
lichenstein and san marino so
that suddenly at the end of 2008
everything was on the verge of
collapsing
what happened in iceland that made it
the first developed economy in more than
30 years to ask for help from the
international monetary fund in october
2008.
when we think of the great recession of
2008 we automatically think of wall
street and the real estate bubble
however the scenario that unfolded on
this island nestled in the icy waters of
the north atlantic was a totally
different experience
within a few months iceland a country of
just over 350 000 inhabitants
faced chaos a near total collapse what
we're going to tell you in this video
that we've made together with value
school is the story of one of the
biggest financial bubbles of all times
the story of a country that in just a
few years went from being a place known
for fishing
gazers and volcanoes to becoming an
international financial center
[Applause]
are you ready to join us on the cold
shores of the island known as the land
of
fire and ice well let's get started
[Applause]
[Music]
reykjavik 2007 the icelandic capital
traditionally known for being the
world's most northernmost capital and
having the oldest active parliament
is now also a hotspot in financial
circles that's partly thanks to the fact
that
the icelandic economy is experiencing a
golden age
since 2003 economic growth has averaged
6.4 percent
annually the local stock index the ice x
has just touched 7
900 points since the lows at the end of
2001 the icelandic stock market has seen
an
average annual revaluation of almost 60
percent
at this time in 2007 icelanders have
become the real kings of the party
their wealth is growing steadily and
house prizes in the capital have tripled
in just over three years
more range rovers are sold in the
country than in sweden and denmark
combined
despite the fact that these countries
have a combined population almost 50
times larger than iceland's
the countries multinationals banks and
major investors are buying up companies
around the world
real estate assets and even soccer teams
and that's not all the average family is
now three times richer than it was in
2003 just four years ago it is the
icelandic
economic miracle
but wait a minute stop more than 10
years have passed since these unusually
golden years in iceland can we really
say that it was a miracle what caused
this economic explosion what was behind
such a frenzy listen up
the bank run
do you understand the origins of this
whole story we have to go back to 2003
the country's big banks had just been
privatized and
at that time interest rates in the us
and the euro zone were much louder than
in iceland this scenario was taken
advantage of by the three
largest icelandic banks landsbanki
bernard banky
and kelp thing to intensively develop a
banking operation known as carry trade
which consists of borrowing at a low
interest rate and then investing in
assets that generate higher interest
rates
in this particular case icelandic banks
took advantage of the country's high
sovereign debt rating and also of having
the community banking passport iceland
is not a member of the eu but is a
member of the european economic area to
borrow in euros short term and to lend
long term in iceland where rates were
already higher and that's not all
you see this same process also had
another consequence iman and the banks
had to sell the euros they received to
buy krona fast gradually raising their
exchange rates and so in order to
prevent the corona from appreciating too
much the central bank of iceland
constantly increased the money supply to
such an extent that it ended up
increasing almost six-fold in just five
years this in turn led to rising
inflation in the country which
for example drove up the value of assets
and thus the supposed solvency of
banking operations and so the cycle
repeated
it was a seemingly roundabout business
that soon attracted many foreign
investors as well and exactly the same
thing was also done by icelandic
companies and households they borrowed
abroad to acquire assets at home
houses stock exchange assets vehicles
etc etc this phenomenon is precisely
what explains the huge revaluation in
house and stock market prices that we
mentioned earlier
well the fact is that in this context
the icelandic banks exploited the
abundant liquidity in the international
markets as much as they could to repeat
this process again and again and again
even from 2006
onwards icelandic banks working through
subsidiaries branches on the mainland
and also through online media started to
aggressively market to retail customers
in eu countries such as the netherlands
and the uk
the so-called icesave deposits with the
basic feature being relatively high
rates and when this was not enough
either they began to ask for billions
from central banks
including the european central bank all
this led to a 12-fold increase in the
size of their assets in less than a
decade
[Music]
thus as you can see in this graph the
assets of the three main icelandic banks
amounted to an impressive
10 times the national gdp so that you
can get an idea of a huge hole that
could be created if things went wrong
icelandic banks owed huge amounts of
money mostly in foreign currency and on
a short-term basis in other words they
were forced to constantly refinance this
debt
and of course as international market
conditions become more difficult due to
the financial crisis and the real estate
bubble in countries such as the united
states the situation of icelandic banks
became very sticky
very quickly customer term deposits
began not to be renewed the wholesale
funding market between banks known as
the interbank market began to close
amid a huge wave of growing distrust the
european central bank for its part
stopped lending to icelandic banks
because of their risk
and to top it all off the rating
agencies were slashing their ratings
the situation deteriorated very quickly
and the central bank of iceland reacted
by raising interest rates to 15
to prevent capital flight and it seemed
to work at first but when lehman
brothers collapsed in september 2008 and
panic took hold of the markets
everything came crashing down it was as
if a nuclear bomb had exploded in
iceland's financial system
remember that these banks in order to
maximize the profitability of carry
trade strategies finance themselves very
short-term in order to lend
long-term the result is that they had to
constantly refinance themselves but of
course when that was no longer possible
and they were forced to repay huge
amounts of money in foreign currency
that they did not have the banks were
suddenly faced with an imminent collapse
97 of the banking sector collapsed in a
matter of
three days gudrun johnson member of the
commission
studying the crisis in iceland
keep in mind also that unlike other
countries the gigantic amount of debt
incurred by the banks made any
government bailout totally unthinkable
it was simply not feasible
so at this point banks had to start
liquidating their chrono-denominated
assets to repay loans in euros and
dollars
in other words they sold huge amounts of
krona to buy euros and dollars on the
markets to pay off their debts this
depressed the price of the kroner
something that was aggravated by the
massive outflow of capital from
international investors that began to
take place
it made perfect sense that no one wanted
to have their money in bankrupt
icelandic banks
to give you an idea during 2008 the
coroner lost almost 85 percent of its
value
[Music]
suddenly banks companies and households
had assets in krona that were worth less
and less and huge amounts of debt in
euros dollars pounds or swiss francs
they didn't even have the money to
import goods now at this point the
question that comes up is how on earth
did iceland cope with this kind of
cataclysm what kind of measures did they
take what was the cost of this brutal
collapse
well let's take a look a clean slate
[Music]
in october 2008 when it all blew up
iceland's external debt was equivalent
to 500
of gdp and 32 times the foreign exchange
reserves of the country's central bank
it was practically a perfect storm and
the financial system was truly broken
to deal with this difficult situation
the government passed the so-called
emergency law number 15
2008 which among other things empowered
it to take control of the banks and make
the decisions it deemed appropriate with
respect to their management
well once control was taken it was
decided to incorporate and
capitalize three new banks to which the
national assets and liabilities as well
as the healthy assets of the three large
failed banks could be transferred the
idea was that these banks could operate
at the same time
as the old ones were liquidated
[Music]
of course at the time it was a very
controversial decision and the fact is
that
in this way what the government did was
basically to bail out the deposits of
icelandic savers while leaving some 6.7
billion euros of british and dutch
investors deposits trapped in the old
banks the situation that prompted the
united kingdom to apply anti-terrorism
laws to freeze icelandic assets to
secure payments
[Music]
in the end an agreement was reached
foreign depositors were given priority
in the liquidation which allowed them to
recover their savings this was not
achieved by the rest of the creditors
and bondholders
then secondly the government asked for
help from the international monetary
fund which dispersed some 2.1 billion
u.s dollars to help stabilize the
icelandic economy this amount was
supplemented by
bilateral financing lines from other
countries this may not
seem like a lot of money but remember
that we are talking about a country of
just
over 350 000 inhabitants
[Music]
and finally the third major measure that
was taken with the intention of
stabilizing the currency was to
establish capital controls this was done
to limit capital outflows
which would prevent the coroner from
promoting further these were the three
major crisis response measures taken by
the icelandic government
over the years initiatives were also
taken such as partial write-offs for
over-indebted families and companies for
example mortgage balances
exceeding 110 of the value of the home
were forgiven for its part the
government also cut non-financial public
spending substantially by 12.7 percent
which was one of the largest adjustments
of all
oecd countries
this is how total disaster was avoided
and it was achieved largely thanks to
the help of the international community
however
this was a strategy that created many
myths but with the numbers in hand it
had a very significant
impact a steep
bill
iceland's exit from the crisis brought
with it huge waves of myths but the
truth is that
looking at the data the public bailout
of the financial system was the second
largest of all developed countries only
behind ireland
in total the government and the central
bank had to disperse more than 3.24
billion euros to clean up the financial
system we're talking about 20
of gdp and around 7 370 dollars per head
almost 23
600 on average for a family of three
people not to mention of course the huge
capital losses of families or the really
bad years that icelanders went through
until things stabilized
in short this is a story of the great
crisis that almost sunk iceland the fact
that it did not happen was because this
country was one of the richest in the
world and also because it had generous
international assistance
in any case what we have seen is the
story of one of the greatest financial
crises of all time but now it's your
turn
how do you think a country can protect
itself from financial crises
any ideas leave us your answer in the
comments and you know if you found this
video interesting please don't forget to
hit the like button and many thanks once
again to our friends at value school for
their help in preparing this video all
the best
see you next time and if you want to
learn more about politics and hear even
more of my lovely voice
you can join us at reconsider media we
have a podcast at reconsider media.com
podcast see you there